hi I'm astronaut Nicole stopped and I'm
gonna answer your questions about space
on Twitter
this is space support from Zara are we
saying then the tanning in space would
happen just in virtue of being in space
because cosmic radiation and unfiltered
UV rays when you're in space of course
you're above you know the bulk of the
atmosphere and that makes it a lot more
dangerous to be exposed to the sun's
radiation so we try to protect ourselves
from that for the windows that we do
look through most of them have a UV
filter on them which helps protect us
but there are some windows that don't so
we know in particular what those are and
we try to really limit our time in front
of them all right Joey Pavan elly is
there Wi-Fi in space yes there's Wi-Fi
in space you might not be happy with it
because it's not dial-up slow but it is
pretty slow ah Kevin Gomes age limit for
space travel I hope not good I'd really
like to go back there really isn't one
set I think that the criteria is
associated more with your education with
the career and work you've done and also
from you know just a medical and
psychological evaluation how can we
detect and track space debris which
sensors were used and where are they
located all of that tracking is done
from the ground and through other
satellite resources that we have and
they have a whole unit that tracks
debris in space for us and then
communicates with NASA about it one of
my greatest memories of things that I
really remember is being at the window
it was nighttime outside and watching
this streak of light go below me and
floating down to the other end of the
station and asking my crewmates hey what
you know I just saw this oh yeah that's
just you know a microbe meteorite you
know probably entering the atmosphere or
a piece of debris entering the
atmosphere and like like a shooting star
is basically what they told me and I
remember floating there and thinking wow
that was really beautiful and then I
also remember thinking man I'm really
glad I saw that because that means it
didn't hit my spaceship and that's a
really good thing I don't want that
hitting fiction
Adam asked what is the coordinate system
used in orbits and is it the same as non
orbit journeys such as that to the Moon
and Mars
this you know this is a really great
question on the space station for
instance we're flying around the Earth
you can see this model here and the way
we fly you can see this little space
station at the end so this whole space
station this is like forward the whole
space station is moving around the earth
with that point pointing forward the
whole time and we have a coordinate
system associated with that to you know
let us know locations and how the
station is moving you can apply the same
one that we use with this space station
flying around the earth to fly other
like non orbit journeys it can work for
you there's also specialized coordinate
systems all different kinds of them Sam
Anderson do you think eating a large
messy sandwich should be harder or
easier in space I don't know that would
be harder or easier but it probably
would be Messier things tend to float
around so if you let go of your sandwich
is probably going to come apart in the
bridal float and the stuff inside will
float around of course we do silly
astronaut tricks with food and drink all
the time pants later how long does it
take to get to the moon and how fast can
you go in space now this is a really
great question you know it it takes
about two days to get to the moon the
way we fly to the moon so we launched
off the earth we get going really fast
and we circle the earth and we do this
what they call slingshot method of then
accelerating ourselves toward toward and
then around the moon that's all really
cool orbital mechanics that goes on
there and it's really neat to me how we
can use the gravity and spin of our own
planet to accelerate a spaceship off
into space on the space shuttle
we traveled at 17,500 miles an hour the
guys that went to the moon about 24,000
miles an hour ten days earns what do you
do if you're an astronaut and you
experience serious health problem while
in space well hopefully your crewmates
will be able to take care of you a
number of us trained to be medical
officers on board a mission and we have
probably any supply you could possibly
need to take care of anything and we are
in constant communication with our
medical
on the ground worst case if we needed to
get somebody home we could we could do
that in our rescue vehicle or the Soyuz
spacecraft I never received any training
about what to do if somebody dies in
space I guess you deal with that real
time but we can always get somebody home
if we have to all right from Jesus what
happens to astronauts when they come
back from space do they have any health
problems or things they have to greatly
readjust to well the main thing that you
greatly have to readjust to is gravity
your body just I think forgets at first
what being in this load of gravity is
like and so you feel really really heavy
there are other things that go on with
our bodies that we try to counteract
while we're in space so that we're
healthy when we get home like your you
know bones and muscles really starting
to you know go away because you don't
need them when you're working in space
so we exercise a couple hours a day up
there to try to stay in shape so when we
come home where we're feeling good and
there are things that we really don't
quite understand yet about the way
radiation affects us and also you know
we're seeing things with people's eyes
where vision is changing and we think
it's because of this pressure that you
get on the back of your eye but we're
really trying to figure that out too the
question is how can I be hired in NASA
and what is it like I strongly encourage
you to apply for a job at NASA working
at NASA was absolutely it's the best job
I could think of I started out at the
Kennedy Space Center working on the
shuttle program and helping getting the
space shuttles ready to fly for for
crews and in that one job I got to move
around Kennedy Space Center and work in
the launch control center and then move
and work in the orbiter processing
facility which was like this big hangar
where the orbiter came back in you got
it the vehicle ready to fly again and so
through that one job with NASA I got to
see all aspects of how we get spaceships
ready to fly and then before becoming an
astronaut I moved out to the Johnson
Space Center in Houston and for two
years I got to work on the shuttle
training aircraft which was this
modified corporate jet that we use to
basically dive at the runway and train
astronauts how to land the Space Shuttle
and in doing that job I got to wear this
really cool helmet in the t-38 trainer
jets and
and the shuttle training aircraft as we
flew and trained astronauts and then
applied to be an astronaut and was
selected and for 15 years I worked in
the astronaut office and had the
opportunity to fly in space twice and
spend over three months living and
working on the space station everything
about it is ultimately about improving
life on Earth and I think there's no
better place to work than one where you
know you're doing some kind of greater
good work for not just yourself and your
family but for everybody that we share
this planet with so highly recommend it
how often are additional supplies sent
up to aid the ISS okay pretty regularly
actually and we do that with a number of
different of cargo ships that get sent
to the station I would say it's once
every couple months that we're sending
things we've got two US vehicles that we
use to get supplies to the space station
one of them can actually bring things
home too we have a Japanese cargo
vehicle and a Russian cargo vehicle so
there's pretty regular resupply going on
the five space programs that are
involved with the international space
station are the US through NASA the
Russian Space Agency the Japanese Space
Agency Canadian and European it's really
great because we have this international
partnership we share food we share
supplies we distribute that across the
station as necessary and the Russians
can fly things on the US vehicles and
the same is true for all the other
countries as well this is from Danny
skorca and he asks what will power SLS
once the old shuttle engines are used up
that is an excellent question you know
sadly the way SLS is being developed
those engines wouldn't be reused so I
think that right now they're looking at
how do they build more of them and the
amount of time that we'll have between
SLS missions I think they'll they'll
have the time to build new engines to
power SLS and hopefully we'll have new
kinds of propulsion coming along as well
Michael Moreno wondering if the
astronauts on the Internet
Space Station ever get bored I hope not
I was never bored in space there's the
window to look out see earth below you
sharing stories with your crewmates
floating around flying and you can even
bring things that you enjoy doing on
earth so I had the chance to paint while
I was in space my crewmates played music
in space this is not a place where you
get bored when a ship blows up in space
where do the pieces go do they just
float around in the abyss forever and
ever
well some of them might I suppose
depending on how fast they went away
from the explosion but ultimately like
if something blew up in low-earth orbit
it would orbit for some period of time
would eventually slow down and get
dragged into the atmosphere and burn up
so this is my helmet that I wore when I
flew in the t-38 trainer Jets which are
the little NASA Jets it's an Air Force
trainer jet two seats it's got a visor
that is like a Sun Visor and also a
clear visor you always want to keep that
down a lot of times in the movies you'll
see the actors without their oxygen mask
on there's not a time unless you're on
the ground in a jet that you don't wear
your oxygen mask NASA was really great
they they would provide these helmets to
you and they kind of customized them to
you you could pretty much get anything
you wanted on the back I just did my
name which I thought was simple and nice
and I really like the color blue thanks
for watching I'm astronaut nicole stott
and I hope you learned a little
something about space